c'est une oeuvre en hommage aux victimes
de 13 novembre qui a été volé ce week
end au bataclan c'est un sujet de bfm tv
on regarde ce qu'ils en disent
et on s'en reparle juste après c'est
glauque c'est moche
la voilà c'est un an avant elle les
images un personnage peint au pochoir et
à la peinture blanche sur l'une des
portes du bataclan les parisiens avaient
découvert il ya six mois en juin 2018 et
bien les voleurs ont découpé la porte à
la meule voilà l'équipe du bataclan est
évidemment très choquée qu'il l'avait
laissée à cet endroit là justement pour
qu'elle soit visible qu'elle soit libre
et visible de tous les dons qu'ils l'ont
volé on espère évidemment qu'ils
retrouveront les voleurs alors l'artiste
a offert son le pochoir originale qui
avait permis de faire cette oeuvre à la
police pour peut-être éventuellement
aider
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ludivine je
sais que ça vous a révolté voix mais
totalement mais qui fait ça qui fait ça
qui qui vole quelque chose qui est la
poype enfin une oeuvre d'art déjà mais
en plus par rapport à la tragédie qu'on
a connu en un drame qui s'est passé se
rappelle bien 130 db ce soir l'homme à
bhl 4 113 blessés à paris et en
seine-saint-denis 90 morts au bataclan
voilà c'est innommable moi j'arrive même
pas j'ai pas de jets pas de mots et je
comprends encore moins que le docteur
cohen ne soit pas choquer mais je vais
expliquer c'est pour les esprits simples
ce que tu viens de dire si ça va bien
mais je vous laisse à les y développer
vos arguments et les caraïbes ou si vous
vous êtes aussi choqué 28 non mais moi
je suis une grosse voleuse je n'aurais
pas osé non mais franchement c'est vrai
que déclare le street art comme on
l'appelle où parfois il ya des espèces
d'oeuvres d'artistes incroyable qui se
balade dans paris en province ça on est
on est tenté on se dit mais c'est à
croire que ses protégés est ce qu'il ya
un système de sécurité star amel a
symboliquement franchement avoir découpé
la porte à cet endroit là précisément où
quand même tout le monde sait ce qui
s'est passé et a en plus je vous payez
un côté un peu les yeux une tristesse
dans nombre dans ce dans ce dessein et
tous et le tec faut vraiment être un peu
un peu tombé sur la tête et est ce que
par ailleurs vous dit cette porte là
elle est très symbolique vous pensez que
les voleurs savent exactement ce qu'ils
ce dont il s'agissait et jean-michel
camarades vous attendent donc s'y est
beaucoup plus connu pour ses mises en
scène et son marketing
que pour la qualité de son travail même
si moi-même j'apprécie deuxième là on
rappelle pardonne aux téléspectateurs
alors j'ai développé un artiste
contemporain de street art
sa spécialité c'est effectivement
d'aller mettre des pochoirs et de taguer
un peu les les les différents mobiliers
urbains par ailleurs maintenant il est
également exposé notamment il a fait un
coup de maître
c'est ce concept est assez comme ça où
il allait d'une oeuvre
voilà aux enchères elle s'est
autodétruite pendant la vente alors
qu'elle venait d'être adjugée à 1,2
millions donc voilà il est adepte de ce
genre de coup voilà on notait les 6 4
donc ça c'est la première chose
concernant lorsqu'il la deuxième chose
c'est est que les gens qui ont volé sa
ils ont pas ni volé le bataclan niveau
les banques si ils ont fait un rapt ses
financiers c'est à dire c'est un vol
classique et la troisième chose c'est
que je suis totalement opposé à ce
qu'une salle de spectacle comme le
bataclan devienne un lieu sacré mythique
parce qu'on y à tuer des gens au
contraire moi je trouve ça assez
dramatique et je voudrais citer une
phrase ça va impressionner femme
d'albert kahn qu'il y ait de véritables
tombeaux des morts c'est le coeur des
vivants
alors allez me faire croire que le
bataclan représente le drame absolu qui
s'est produit là bas avec le petit
tableau de banksy qui fait du marketing
à tout va et qui avait décidé d'une
grosse publicité là dedans alors que le
tuyau a traumatisé d'accord vous vous
dites en fait il ya chez bang c'est une
forme de cynisme
il s'est fait de l'amour entre
guillemets sur un événement extrêmement
tragique
vous vous plaignez pas sur un point on
sait par ailleurs vous vous dites
pour sûr le sur le lieu-même vous dites
il faut pas que ça devienne un tombeau
et faut pas que ce soit une voix là si
c'est une cathédrale alors qu'on y fasse
plus de musique c'est fini mais là moi
je suis opposé à ce que matériellement
ça devienne le symbolisme alors
s'annonce vraiment intéressant qu'est ce
que vous lui opposer thibault un
argumentaire repris bien voilà c'est de
la rébellion de bac à sable c'est tout
je sais même pas pourquoi il prend cette
posture envers nous c'est un symbole
cette porte a été volée elle ne me peux
même pas être revendu
on comprend pas ils se sont attaqués à
n'importe quoi il ya des êtres humains
qui sont livrés en kit sans cerveau et
on l'a vu sur cette action là et c'est
tout c'est indéfendable
s'il ya des gens qui veulent passer
devant cette porte tous les jours et se
recueillir
ils en ont le droit et ça a été offert
par banksy donc à partir de là je dirais
pas peur d'entendre aussi la douleur de
ceux qui sont là également
vallat les trois religions ayants droit
de c'est tellement facile d'aller dire
ça aulas la catastrophe il ya volé le
tableau nancy c'est la première pensée
que tout le monde a c'est la première
pensée que j'ai eues mais je trouve ça x
aimant simpliste de dire ça faut
considérer les choses c'est juste un
truc matériel et le bataclan est juste
une salle de spectacle qu'on mette une
stèle devant d'accord mais la vraie
mémoire du bataclan c'est tout le monde
sait le monde collectivement qui doit
apporter la tête les noms dites nous ce
que vous en pensez on va voir justement
ce que vous en pensez avec le hashtag
sécu dlt est-ce que effectivement pour
vous cette tragédie on la porte tout
s'est finalement c'est à nous d'être un
lieu de mémoire ou bien il ya une vraie
valeur symbolique à cette porte qui
avait été orné par l'artiste
banques si le hashtag ccq dlt moi je
serais intéressé de connaître votre
sentiment là-dessus parce
qu'effectivement ça pose des vraies
questions